amazing amazing I heard someone say
vegan and I heard someone say sneakers
yeah can I combine those with vegan
sneakers for sure this man whom you look
like you're a vegan sir and what I'm
saying is you look remarkably absent
just take it as a compliment
so beacon sneakers knee caps cotton two
more suggestions middle of the room pogo
sticks yeah you can say photo sticks you
look so excited hope it sticks leader
back do you program
and let's get one final suggestion the
first one was alopecia and you said
decorative pillows so alopecia
decorative pillows pogo sticks kneecaps
cotton you might need to remind me front
row we'll keep this in your brain is the
end to the night we've had a long
freestyle rap as a rap made up on the
spot based entirely on those suggestions
it is not prepared is not written down
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as bad as you're expecting it to me
if we can roll that my friend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]